so the new men in black trailer has just
dropped and it pretty much seems as if
the series is pressing the big reboot
button men in black in my eyes is a
classic and pretty much the perfect film
from start to finish it perfectly
balances tone dancing between comedy and
action with an expertise that few films
can quite handle the sequels however
massively disappointed me and I felt
really let down by the second and third
film which seemed to go off the rails
slightly yes I remember Michael Jackson
was in it but that was about the only
good bit in the second film I'm happy to
see that this new trailer seems to have
perfectly recaptured the vibe of the
original film to great success Tessa
Thompson seems to be a great fit for the
role in replacing Jay as the
down-to-earth character that is taken
interstellar plot wise and Chris
Hemsworth seems to just be having fun
with the role which is exactly what one
would expect from the actor it's clear
that Sony want to make this as close to
the MCU as possible with Hemsworth
pretty much doing his Thor accent
throughout but hey if it's even half as
good as Thor Ragnarok was then we're in
for a treat it's great to see the aliens
popping up once more and Liam Neeson
makes a fitting replacement to Rip Torn
as the MIB leader so I'm very excited to
see what this delivers to me the movie
seems like a brilliant rejuvenation of
the franchise and I can't wait to see it
in cinemas come 2019 so what your
thoughts on the new men and black
International trailer do you agree with
my comments that the casting is perfect
and what would you hope to see in the
film comment below and let me know and
if you enjoyed this video then please
like it and check out my breakdown of
this week's other big trailer Hellboy
which will be linked at the end this is
a channel for people who are mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this I've been
definition you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]
you